quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo
nuovo io sono fa vj oggi ho portato
pietro perché siccome non c'e voglia di
giocare a chi mi è venuto in mente di
fare una cosa abbastanza carina che
avevo già fatto l'anno scorso ovvero
giocare da abel dato questa è la mia è
la mia maschera di cui piacciono sia
bisogno sono sexy grazie ai sudato con
lo schifo è diversa non mi toccare i
nomi toccanti denuncio togli porca vacca
dai non poteva montare una [ __ ] invece
di te va bene niente
[Musica]
allora ragazzi vi spiego anzi ti spiego
perchè non l'hai dimmi mi devi dire che
cosa fa cosa farvi non vedo una mazza
quel giusto cosa non va bene è un caso
quindi se devo andare avanti mi ci vai
avanti subito con alici fermati in tempo
perché se noi però se l'operazione avrà
particolare non va bene
un corpino bella scusa dai vai giù giù
giù sul suo braccio per quanto è
difficile questa sembra di poco
esatto click no si giunge lì in ora
clicca playnow come capelli e non
sapevano di ok per perfetto ciavatta gli
m moltissimo come non lo è mi cosa
faccio io sto facendo di non sei buono
ma lo sta facendo niente sta facendo
niente no è fermo
il picco io 150 episodi di niente miss
pascal armi fino a verona era facile
però è successo mi fermo
guardo ma cos'è lo senti ma come
hannover
questo era forse l'unico che poteva
riuscire a fare entro oggi va benissimo
i livelli ti scelgo io le posso non ci
mettiamo la vita e mezzo ok facciamo 99
per cento impossible è nata e facciamo
facciamo allora devi saltare cioè tu sei
su una scala di risalita re in un buco a
destra tipo mira l'ho mica se vincevo
non è che mister e privacy combacianti
secondo uno sgambetto a destra più ad
aia e pace c'è una falla di meno si
chiama all'azione geometrica del 35
gradi di lo sospetta aspetta di cui
quando perché la panda che salta e vai
trova purtroppo un po troppo posto stato
troppo poco e vabbè aspetta aspetta
vai
ma che cosa succede se l'esplosione
brillare vai o no no no non so cosa è
successo non capiscono o no questo no
questo successo di sempre un patto alle
cose di me vedere rivedere guarda ma noi
li facciamo mai
non c'è una settimana sta cercando di
fare vista o o o no a cazzo riti e
successo stamane possibile guarda come
un personaggio che non si può far
sentire la questione video di morte cioè
devo fare bene la crisi ma fo
[Musica]
porca vacca come sono fatti i problemi
ma finiscono i pistoni bene se una bella
senza neanche l'unica senza indicazioni
proprio scusatemi se questo livello è
accorta ed troppo hard non ai danni che
cosa devo fare capisci
e lo sono invece tv lanciate le teste in
nei buchi avanti per dire test no non è
per niente un po un po indietro indietro
preside crisi è presa la mano per terra
perché so io
devi lanciarla maria ci sto prima ha
rivisto al angela prima angela non è
preso niente
prendi la testa sono che facciamo donna
che nervi spettacolo giovanna ma dalla
famiglia notarle giosa e che si è
successo ha aperto vento io la guardo
tutte perdute giu libutti hiv aspetta di
proviamo o aspetta ok allora la vicenda
che mi fermo abbiamo sbloccato la
vittoria va bene devi fare leggermente
un tiro più corto è quella prima lettore
più corto più con niente ok più corto
ancora sempre in alto e più corto vai
troppo coraggio
venisse testa porca vacca ai piemontesi
e basta è piano piano piano piano non
farlo fermo in aldo più in alto ma
previsto naldo basta solo capace e
cambiamo livello basta a gesù la prima
volta che ho deciso di giocare è messo
alla fine la mia vita che è in the box
questa questo dovresti capire dove
entrare nella scatola ok propria scheda
una scatola sotto di te rettangolare
le entrate sono a metà del lato destro e
sinistro ok meglio cosa sto facendo
se il segreto per terra appoggiato un
angolo aggrappati ok grappa che ora
prefetto non mollare mai tarzan da anni
moglie di spinta più spinta più speed
perfetto 6 in verticale la sede mare ai
riflessi di un brontosauro morto e cieco
buttati giù e non ti lasciare ma cosa
vuol dire e devi aggrapparti mai che
direziona sinistra no sì no sì no no no
no ma non signorsì nostro che cazzo
l'indicazione al mente di butti a
sinistra con dico poi lascia andare ok
voluti sinistra vai lasciati andare da
detto ma vabbè la non sei capace di
giocare 5 bisogno perché oggi di fare
niente aiutiamo la scheda
ma se succede al perfetto quello che è
successo era perfetto ma io non ho idea
di cosa sia va bene prossimo facciamo
svolto dai c'è uno scontro occhio
nuovamente davanti il traguardo preso un
altro davanti più in fondo leggermente
sopra non hai preso niente preso la
squadra in più hai preso quasi quello
sopra 6 ucciso oggi fortemente ci sono
ci sono sicuro ti piace sì mi piace hai
usato 17 spalle perù 1 lady buttato giù
e ci sono 11 dietro di te non hai preso
niente che ora se la società mi piace
attacchi creta carelli in alto a
sinistra nell'angolo in alto a sinistra
che altre squadre per cedere le persone
sono uniti anche l'altro no più in alto
lancia in alto indietro no più in alto
di lanciarla vai troppo in alto e vabbè
non le pesa mite gloria finito alle
spalle mi manchi una cosa è successo
l'intera pena tra va pure che mi lega a
trova malico guai e da tubi zadra canada
mi fa 100 per cento impossible spies
facciamo questo punto sui pro faceva
molto freddo prima marabotto il flip hai
una bottiglia fin qua ok rovinarla e
farà cadere intesa comunque ci arriva
proprio cervello funziona anche senza
bale prospetta è ucciso un bambino quasi
si possa gran botto lancio in aria
fortissimo di poco di poco e non è
riuscito a porta marca dai gay come 4
basta guardarla calandra butta in aria
ora le mani o guarda guarda a cercare il
pallone
grazie è perfetto e stato bellissimo
ecco cento per cento passi lo spike hold
buy
ok devo allora ti spiego come funziona
nel cadere
questa forza che immagino sia qua
turchesi e così è successo non lo so ma
mi vedrei ti giuro che ho saltato a caso
non l'ho detto devo cadere in questa
forza no non ci fosse qualche ora questo
è stato assurdo mi capiti al momento va
bene così
1111 impossible
non so che casillas con 11 ma ci
proviamo bye bye i miei occhi ok donne
non lo km 62 non mette il milan è anche
vero rimaniamo dai fammi capire come si
fa più salda destra bene hai perso la
testa ottimo progetti come primo
consigliere a volte a destra e poco a
destra salta in alto no non aspettatevi
che lo sai che stai in epoche esempio
anima alta e torna giovedì prima parte
in verticale perfetto o no no mica porca
vacca me stai calmo quando succede
miliardo a dosso alto destra mai
credo di sì io no vai occhio alle
ambizioni play come cazzo fatta
non lo so 1 presente in postivo del
video vediamo a cosa mi fanno scegliere
personaggio mai tecniche questa
quadratura milano va dai tempi di fermo
e mi quando i razzi sono che puntano
verso l'alto
ok va in scena poveri germinario
disamina hai preso in pieno la mia ai
raggiri mai sud finito beh mi spieghi
cosa è successo non lo sai anche tu eh
già perché sono curioso di rivedere le
cagate che faccio scusatemi il problema
è che le vedendole solo dopo non capisco
è stata utile stimato perfetto padova in
area siamo di bussi incredibile se fare
solo questo nella napoli ora hop swing
michero xing inventato mi mancavano vai
vai a pentito afferra tua ferro è no è
no
d'altra parte ha appena ok la settimane
verrà meglio magari anche questo in
volta vengono condito di la posa e dopo
mese con d'offerta ok ok
lo afferma domenico la marca che a
pietro perché di pochissimo genere chi
lascia per prendi lascia no no no no no
no no la chat
prendi lascia poi vediamo un po prima
abbiamo quasi devo fare le membra ceduto
però cosa devo fare
einstein e tranquillo e normale come
norma l'avresti essere mai su al
contrario cioè state presentate in suo
aiuto cosa faccia io voglio niente
no no ai sei un cannone sono in un
cannone si possa vuol dire aver sposato
un canotto
vieni no no no no cercheremo di gioco di
merda facciamo l'ultimo ragazzi basta
visto scassato possiamo già dare
l'ultimo profondi serio vai
poi spiega mi devo saltare narrano a
destra
pian piano ho o non è stato perfetto
destro ancora di no ed è stanco adesso
mi consigli solo in inglese
vai jump up rai trade e rai cioè donini
suoi alti aspetta una delibera
d'iscrizione da fendi col consigli in
italy mai mai chiudiamo
ok anche all'inter di elite ne minerà
risponderà il bayern temi nuovi album on
the light your right to write
ok navate di vertu jump white blood on
the right side cazzo vuol dire già
magistrato non per le palle per scudo
guarda che io insieme agli siria che
curva come la faccia le tre bellissime
va bene va bene va bene ragazzi dire che
possiamo concludere qui l'episodio di
oggi spero che vi sia piaciuto spero che
il bisogno io bendato siano di vostro
grandi
momento cosa sento ragazzi si viene al
momento mi piace anche a risorgere come
descrizione services ed e ci vediamo
prossima visto dai ragazzi
[Musica]